all right you're done let's take a look
at my solution all right so here's what
our ad location function looks like
location settings city name latitude and
longitude just like in our content
provider test we can use get content
resolver to query based upon the content
URI remember that the default location
entry content URI passes all of the
parameters into the database so we can
easily construct a query containing the
location setting to see if it is in the
database yet if it's not then the query
will return an empty set and we should
insert the new city name location
setting latitude and longitude into the
database together